recently I actually saw a woman that I
would deem as an ater higher walking
down the runway and I thought to myself
this is one of the most beautiful women
that I have seen in a long time let's
pull up the
video she is a
super Andrea Mesa she got to meet her
and was so excited she was literally
shaking my guess is that after night
shanus is going to have some super fans
of her own work it [__] Aga
now I'd like to say first I have to deem
this inappropriate for a wife and a
mother sorry guys I do I do have to
preface this but it was actually so
encouraging to see a woman that was so
exceptionally beautiful this is one of
the most beautiful women that I have
seen in a long time